de l'oag de la porte en fait et en fait
à ce moment-là ce coup je me vois mourir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kilian mba pays qui a des maps et qui
reste au paris saint germain c'est
magnifique gilles est ce qu'on peut
avoir les montants parce que c'est vrai
que derrière on voudrait savoir ça alors
yacine et pourquoi parce que on entend
plein de choses on entend on a entendu
300 millions de prime à la signature
mais il ya 100 millions par an est
maintenant en fait on parle de 50
millions par an sur trois ans gilles et
ce sans millions halal c'est le salaire
vous allez donner le salaire salaire 50
millions par an ouais ça fera 150
millions net sur les trois ans et le
real madrid proposé sur cinq ans enfin
même chose ça aurait été la masse et sa
part qu'on a annoncé une prime à la
signature de 300 millions parce qu'à pas
de frais de transfert c'est faux c'est
de faire à son rang la spa sont comtois
exactement 100 ans 130 millions c'est la
france c'est mon pays et quand gilles
dit l'émir est entré dans la danse c'est
totalement faux c'est emmanuel macron
qui va dire lilas il a dit certains mais
attends attends mais
il laisse parler les adultes parce qu'à
cette heure-là les enfants ils vont ils
sont
ce qui veut dire que des conneries quand
ils viennent parler de l'argent tu nies
que des bêtises alors il a sur trois ans
ou mal et là
ça c'est certain ben oui tu as la même
baisse depuis douze ans
et d'un bêtise d'il
ya quatre ans que je vais dire y'a un
truc je comprends pas j'ai 70 ans j'ai
jamais été stressé sur teen d'air et
tout ça tout est bien de m'écrire c'est
lui connaît
[Applaudissements]
je suis un vieux con marché passe côté
singers et wafa tout je voudrais te
rencontrer à 21h15 après l'émission
c'est fatou je sais pas
le jour où je vais me lever c'est mieux
foutu me lever tu vas voir ce que ça va
ça va faire l'effet du vin des milieux
trois mois dans le rôle de transfert
soit gentil sur les seuils je t'ai déjà
dit je te le répète en règle en payant
une personne mes enfants sont au lit
alors là on va pas les a pas embêtés à
3,1 contre haye la 600 millions nets
d'impôts ils veulent où tu vas 6
millions si c'est oui on est droit dans
bien dis ce que tu sais pas qui c'est il
ya une fondation où il est mais tu
connais rien t'as jamais faim dossier de
ta vie donc je connais pas tu as fait tu
as fait que faire des trucs là
j'en ai quatre ans fera pas plaisir
encore faire que voilà tout écrivent non
du tout je suis jamais - bordeaux pas
que
tu veux le voir parce que tu es de
retour sur canal plus avec le flambeau
les aventuriers de chupa capra sachez
que c'est une merveille j'avais adoré la
première voiture en flammes kabala qui
était une cité ne parle ni de bachelor
c'était culte je pense pour moi et je le
redis je pense que c'est au dessus
vous allez devoir survivre pendant 38
jours sans rien
sûr que c'est là parce qu'il n'y a pas
de vie la fina mal criant on va te
construire nous mêmes tout construire
avec quoi anne nos mains peut-être
devront dépasser la fin on crève la
dalle de déjeuner ni de dîners quoi la
fatigue a bien dormi lui tombe bien oui
mais trahison évidemment que je voulais
travailler en compte
seul de ses 14 aventurier et succédera
l'été est remportée
50 euros une somme folle rien
n'empêchera gagné 450 euros
hier et fait que commencer les rôles ont
fait vomir c'est le seul moyen de faire
du poids rapidement
c'est la patronne c'est elle avait sauvé
chéri d'amour
psg mula quand je te vois dit moi quand
je vois des quand je vois des gens comme
ça en fait j'ai l'impression de revenir
à l'époque du coït frère j'ai
l'impression qu'on est confiné si on
ratera total j'ai l'impression que leïla
bekhti c'est un docteur oui madame
bekhti est ce que vous êtes en mesure de
nous dire
quand est ce qu'on aura les premiers
vaccins c'est pas grave j'ai plus
l'habitude d'avoir déjanté pacte est
bloquée à cannes d'un shérif ça va
bloquer à cannes mais
voilà je veux dire alors des parfums la
leçon n'est pas où on va pas te mentir
c'est pas non plus le meilleur sont
connus sur ces 15 dernières années
sur la petite lucarne on a fait mieux là
il ajoute on voulait te dire qu'on
t'aime que tu es formidable dans le
flanc beenie man tu es toujours belge
via les sim est mort et que tu sais que
tu sais comme tu content pour moi et là
tout
va c'était un plaisir de te parler
[Applaudissements]
après
c'était aller
sachez c'est un sas et la technologie
est là nous ici on vit en 2002 où les
duplex en fait
stability marche c'est super mais bon
sait pas où ça va leïla
leïla france on adore parce que c'est un
nouveau concept
c'est un nouveau concept extraordinaire
c'est à dire que tu es là tu mois et on
est content de voir à la personne on se
dira et on imagine tu penses que tu peux
penser ce que tu peux dire ça nouveau
concept d'une interview que j'aime
énormément leila on t'aime
mais si
cela
change d'opérateur lien je l'aï la honte
et tétouan à sion d'amour qu'est ce que
j'ai entendu déclaration d'amour
déclaration d'amour tu veux faire une
déclaration assis à moi
alors j'ai rasin a dit
leila on voulait faire une déclaration
d'amour à jonathan non c'est réussi toi
je pense non pour toi ok de ce que j'ai
entendu ça on dirait quand on est vous
savez le bescherelle quand il ya des
trucs à tron mais tu dois remplacer le
verbe entre parenthèses là on sait que
c'est le verbe aimer non c'est passé mme
aubry
il est là
merci
grâce à
lui seul et d'amour et bravo pour ce
duplex je pense que tu te restera lente
et images télé ça
un mot sur quatre a
joué au hameau sur
voulez vous de découvrir que notre
invité veut nous dire c'est parti on
joue tous tu pourquoi mettre en place
vendredi matin alors que soit il a
seront au travail dans sa ville de
sarcelles elle va se retrouver coincé
dans son ascenseur et pour la jeune
femme le cauchemar ne fait que commencer
de l'eau provenant d'une fuite de
canalisation va commencer à inonder la
cabine et le niveau va monter à une
vitesse fulgurante
alors qu'elle est au deuxième sous-sol
de son immeuble soit hélas pas parvenir
à contacter son frère par téléphone elle
va réussir à s'extirper par le haut de
l'ascenseur aujourd'hui soit il a est
une miraculée mais cet épisode l'a
traumatisée accompagné de ses frères
elle a décidé de témoigner dans tpm p
c'est un truc de fou tu es magnifique en
plus merci merci d'être là merci c'est
vous remercie à yap d'être avec nous qui
est le frère de la victime bravo en tout
cas pour ce que tu as fait aussi si on
avait tu as ta place mais je crois que
si c'est une panique totale
qu'as tu te dis quoi là
en fait à ce moment là je me rendais pas
compte de la chose parce que pour moi
c'est une journée normale je me rende au
travail je travaille avec au fond où je
travaille dans le même établissement que
mon frère est donc je prends l'ascenseur
je vais récupérer la voiture et je pense
que vous entendez le bruit mais d'un
coup en fait j'arrive l'ascenseur
indique le chemin de il se bloque et
visions d'horreur en fait j'ai l'eau qui
monte moi ce moment là je me rends
vraiment pas compte de la gravité de la
chose parce que pour moi c'était juste
je pensais que l'ol allait m'arriver au
tibia la limite et puis basta est ce que
je sais c'est que j'appelle le bouton
d'urgence jo qui sonne et pas de réponse
je raisonne encore une fois pas de
réponse moi j'étais là champagne a
incité plus fait vite fait du loyer
patrouiller l'eau monte ouais je voyais
l'eau monte et comme je vous ai déjà
bien regarder le
tien autour de moi en temps normal et là
en fait quand je tourne la tête c'était
son ma droite je roulais à la porte de
l'ascenseur et je vois que de l'eau
arrive de la porte en fait deux duos en
face quand je regarde en bas je vois que
l'eau a ri et que l'eau monte et qu'elle
arrive aussi par le haut dans l'ue mais
à ce moment là c'est pas encore le
cauchemar j'avais extrêmement peur
l'asthme est encore
là comme vous voyez mon frère dans l'eau
ouais en fait je me posais la question
derrière lolo est à caniveaux et en fait
à ce moment là ce qu'on me voit mourir
je me vois mourir et quand et comme mon
frère il me dit arrête de pleurer arrête
de pleurer mais est stressé il essaie
d'ouvrir la porte de l'ascenseur je
l'entend crier j'arrive pas j'arrive pas
un maximum moi ce moment là je me suis
dit c'est bon c'est ma faim c'est ma
faim donc je panique je descends
j'essaie d'ouvrir la porte de
l'ascenseur je pousse toutes mes forces
et j'ai fait de vous un thème puissant
parce que j'entends décrié j'en ai crié
crié est impossible d'ouvrir un poste
d'ouvrier elle tape elle crie elle qui
est appris j'ai entendu crier
dirais c'est bon à la tête sous l'eau je
pense que j'étais je suis venu de sortie
pour enfin repartir procès de basso au
niveau zéro pendant je courais je fais
j'étais en train de faire le deuil d'une
joie pure et un master vient où elle est
morte noyée et où j'ai donc on a réussi
à apaiser la porte du niveau zéro avec
momo notre ère il y avait avait aussi un
voisin et j'ai sauté du jeu - 2
donc j'étais au dessus donc là là je me
rends c'était bien parce que lui c'est
bon elle est vivante mais après je
pensais que j'avais une trappe il n'y
avait pas de trappe qu'est ce que je
vais faire là je me sentais impuissant
et là j'ai dit j'ai ramené mois un
tournevis quelque chose vous dévissé vis
par vis
mais je vais faire ça je verse haye a
pris jusqu'à d'un coup je vais je me
tourne je voyais ses jours fin je vois
un peu de lumière je vois qu'il ya des
pompiers qui ont ouvert la porte ils
voient qu'ils la sorte comme ça j'ai un
relâchement là je cours dans l'eau je
vais au parking je saute dans l'eau
c'est incroyable malgré elle bravo pont
pis encore il
[Applaudissements]
ya une petite révolution dans le
concours miss france pour la toute
première fois une femme transgenre
pourra conclure concourir pour devenir
miss france ça s'appelle andrea fur et
au delà plus restera donc la première
candidate rongeurs à se présenter au
concours miss ile de france qui se
déroulera le 19 juin prochain l'actrice
de 19 ans qui avait été notamment révélé
dans le téléfilm il est elle qui parle
justement de la transidentité va donc
concourir pour la couronne suis né dans
mauvais corps alors une candidate
rongeurs se présente pour la toute
première fois au concours une bonne
chose
est ce que cette question une candidate
transgenres se présente pour la première
fois au concours une bonne chose et la
question par direct un mois et à 3
points sur lesquels j'aimerais échanger
à l'ailé mendicité pas c'est déjà sur
les règles direct de miss france je
croyais donc quand on veut plus qu'il
est pour
pour pour se présenter à miss france il
ya déjà le la question est est ce que on
est une femme
c'est une grande question c'est
peut-être hors sujet mais en tout cas
moi je pense que non parce qu'il ya
plein de d'études qui ont été établis et
on ça prouve que ce n'est pas une femme
déjà bien 6
2 on dit que normalement on est pas tous
avoir fait de la chirurgie sauf si elle
et réparatrice bambou vent patrice la
sarre et par desalle et par quoi ça
répare le
ton est particulièrement intolérable je
ne crois pas vraiment le temps mais
vraiment c'est un
jugement de valeur c'est juste que ça un
sujet suprême en portant des roses et
des rameaux mais comme vous osez dire
comme des soirées dans les importants
c'est le sait la communication que ça
fait là dessus sur les jeunes filles qui
veulent se présenter on parle pas de la
boucherie qui est faite sur ces
transgenres
mais vous savez ce que c'est que ce
salon la promotion on en fait tout une
promotion commune
mais elle sans un mot de sa bouche la
violence et monsieur rappaz demande au
racing et manqué de respect à des
dizaines de mélanger non pas de la dgi
son qui sont ici montre or ce n'est pas
du tout mais ici je sais vous attaquez
toujours mais c'est toujours les mêmes
en cédant la wii c'est de vous en faites
vous n'avez pas d'arguments donc vous
m'attaquez vous ne parlez mallmann
masquer une partie oui
juste revenir sur le système de vous ce
que vous parliez de critères il ya un
critère et vous évoquiez la greater elle
elle répond à tous les critères elle
répond à tous les critères puisque
j'étais méchant je peux terminer je vous
en prie merci beaucoup vous évoquiez la
chirurgie il s'agit pas ici d'une
chirurgie esthétique mais je considère
là qu'il s'agit d'une forme de chirurgie
réparatrice puisqu'elle n'est pas né
dans le bon corps donc moi à partir du
moment où cette jeune femme est une
femme justement il n'y a plus de sujets
il n'y a plus de question c'est à dire
que elle va concourir comme les autres
elle répond par ailleurs à tous les
autres critères elle n'est pas tatoué
elle n'est pas mariée elle n'est pas
social est pas cela